hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar practical
considerations in the design of
bottom-up mass spectrometry based
proteomics methods i'm judy or oracle a
birds and i'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
is made possible by an open educational
grant from agilent Agilent has had no
input in the selection of speakers
content or mode of presentation let's
get started you can post questions to
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker
Sandra Spencer PhD the proteomics
platform manager in the Morin lab at the
BC Cancer Research Center dr. Spencer's
undergraduate degrees are in chemistry
and biochemistry
at that time she did research with dr.
Kevin Suge at the University of Texas at
Arlington investigating the toxic
components secreted by the fish killing
algae from museum parvum she did
graduate work in aerosol chemistry and
mass spectrometry instrumentation under
the supervision of dr. Gary glitch at
the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill her thesis was on real-time
analysis of aerosol particle composition
using novel ambient ionization and gas
phase separation techniques dr. Spencer
did her postdoctoral research in the
McAuliffe laboratory at the University
of Washington there she primarily worked
on method development for targeted
proteomics and improvement of nano
liquid chromatography robustness by
implementing robotic solutions dr.
Spencer will now begin her presentation
thank you for that wonderful
introduction so most of this work was
actually performed at the University of
Washington during my postdoc which is
why it's all on Washington u-dub
background even though I am currently in
Vancouver at the BC Cancer Agency so I'd
like to start this out by asking and
thinking about why we even want to do
proteomics so if you think about the
central dogma of biology we start with
DNA that's transcribed into mRNA which
is translated into proteins and if we
think about what each of these things do
the DNA is basically the ultimate
potential of the cell it's what's
possible what you could make whereas the
mRNA does tell us something about what
the cell is trying to do what the cell
wants to do but proteins proteins are
what makes it happen they're they're
really the functional capability of a
cell and I mean they are harder to
measure we're pretty good at measuring
mRNA rate and so you may ask why not
just measure mRNA and infer protein
concentration from that so if we did
that if we measure the mRNA abundance
the probability of observing a given
protein based on its mRNA abundance does
increase as shown in this graph however
if we're trying to predict the abundance
of a protein based on the abundance of
mRNA that's actually not so
straightforward so if we we look at this
correlation there's an r-squared of
between about point 3.6 there are lots
of studies that have shown this and just
to exemplify this let's let's take one
little slice of this data look at the
mRNA abundance of log10 molecules or
love 10 molecules per cell and if we
look at that we can have anywhere from a
hundred to ten to the eight molecules
per cell of the protein okay so so
that's six orders of magnitude
difference and so so we can't really
predict based on the mRNA abundance the
protein abundance were very bad at that
so we want to do proteomics we want to
measure these
proteins and perhaps we want to measure
their post translational modification
which regulate the activity of the
protein the localization of the protein
how long the protein lasts we might want
to do this to get a readout of what the
DNA is doing so for example in
Alzheimer's disease there is a DNA
mutation that creates April efore
instead of enable III protein and that
puts you at high risk for Alzheimer's
disease we can look at post
translational modifications as an
indicator of the cell status status and
various signaling pathways and in these
proteins also act in disease and we'll
talk a little bit about all of these
different things during this
presentation
so why is this difficult why is why is
it so much harder to measure proteins
than RNA well one of the big things is
the complexity of the sample and another
big thing is the dynamic concentration
range so let's think about the proteins
just in this is for serum from Anderson
at all in 2002 and what they did was
look at the concentration of a ton of
proteins in serum now note that this
y-axis is on a log scale and there are
10 orders of magnitude from the most
abundant protein in plasma to the least
abundant protein in plasma okay so this
is huge and this is a really difficult
analytical challenge if we think about
10 orders of magnitude this would be
like trying to find a Great Dane between
Earth and Pluto ok another another thing
cuz that's really big it's really hard
to imagine how far Pluto is away right
other than it's really really far away
so what if we had a little kid painting
on the walls and you take the red
pigment out of that paint you dig into
that get to the ion the iron ion that's
making it actually red and that is 10
orders of magnitude difference in size
between that child and the atom so it's
a lot it's hard to measure all on the
same scale
and it's a very complex mixture your
samples not just proteins in different
samples of different amounts of proteins
and other things in them
just think about urine and skeletal
muscles say they have different amounts
of water even though for both of them
yes water is the most abundant the most
abundant compound in urine were super
salty we have a very say line saline
solution so we have urea and sodium
chloride and at the very very bottom of
this composition list we have some other
ions proteins hormones metabolites just
a little bit of those we don't have a
lot whereas if we look at skeletal
muscle the second most most abundant
compound is protein followed closely by
liquids and then other things and so
obviously these two samples are going to
require two very different methods to
analyze the protein right so if we
thought about this in terms of a
haystack right these things we want to
look at are this haystack and if we're
doing the cattle omics we're trying to
find a needle in a haystack right
because the needle is so different right
if I say creatine and urea those things
are very very different and I might be
able to use chemical methods to enrich
for them
however proteins are all very similar
chemically right so this is kind of like
trying to look for hay in a haystack if
I'm looking for April type of protein e
in the entire proteome this is this is
going to be a very difficult challenge
now I want to switch gears a little bit
and talk about the two different types
of proteomic experiments that you can do
right we can do discovery experiments
which is asking the questions what
proteins are in my sample and this tends
to be a very very commonly asked
question what's here why is this
different why is disease a different
than healthy but we can also do a
targeted experiment and there are
certain instances where we want to do a
targeted experiment and that's when we
want to ask the questions our proteins a
B and C in my sample and some pros and
cons of these two in the discovery
experiment you don't have to know what
you're looking for you don't have to
have a hypothesis about what is there
and what's not there it's supposedly
unbiased there are certain certain more
and less biased discovery techniques out
there and this slow and it requires a
really nice machine and so it's really
expensive on the other hand targeted
experiments can be very very fast
they're relatively inexpensive and you
get a higher sensitivity because you're
looking exactly what you want to see
exactly at what you want to know you're
asking a very targeted hypothesis
however if you don't know to look for it
you're not going to see it ever right
you're going to have to go back to those
samples and analyze them again if you
come up with a different hypothesis but
in this talk my goal or one of my goals
is to convince you that sometimes we
need to break up with discovery
proteomics right it sounds really nice
we're all very scared of not seeing
something that that might be there but
if you know what you're looking for in a
proteome if you want to run an assay a
lot if you want to reduce your assay
cost you might need to do targeted
proteomics okay and so we're going to
talk from from here for the end about
different ways to develop a targeted
proteomic method specifically
quantitative targeted proteomic methods
okay and I'm going to show you how to do
this in two easy steps what we want to
do
is start with this list of targeted
proteins and turn it into a refined SRM
table right so step one is that you're
going to do some stuff to get a list of
peptides that you want to look at and
then you're going to do some mass
spectrometry magic to check these
peptides out and get your refined SRM
table right super simple right well
we'll walk through a bunch of different
ways to do it so the first way we could
do this I like to call it the
spray-and-pray method so what we're
going to do is take one of these
proteins that were interested in we will
highlight all the tryptic peptides so
we're using trypsin usually for
digestion just because it's very very
reproducible and predictable okay so
we'll look at all of our tryptic
peptides and then you go and buy all
these tryptic peptides you pray to the
mass spec gods that be that some of them
work you run them and you get your SRM
table based on what worked so there's a
few good things and bad things about
this right it's expensive for one and
uses mass spectrometry so we like that
part all right we like actually
collecting this data to look at it but
it's really expensive and having had to
do this a couple times it's it's
somewhat infuriating to go through and
then you don't know if it's peptide
that's bad or the instruments better if
your column one it's just a little bit a
little bit time-consuming and tedious it
seems so we can do better than just
guessing check right we can we can
predict what we're going to see we're
going to use an educated guess now to
get from our list of proteins to our SRM
table we'll do the same thing we'll take
our protein will digest it in silico
predict what peptides are going to come
out but we're just going to do that on
the computer right well we're just going
to use a computer hope that we narrowed
this list down well enough on the
computer for things like peptide length
right really short peptides don't fly
well really long peptides don't fly well
so we're gonna have an intermediate
peptide length the good hydrophobicity
for chromatography we're not going to
have a whole lot of amino acids that can
get oxidized
and then we'll do the same thing we'll
buy those ones and run them and this
this sometimes works so let me show you
this for for one protein so here's a
protein sequence and a CSP predictor in
purple here to predict all of the
peptides that might come out of this
right now I just want to note that the
highlighted brown portion is the
sequence that I actually got we'll talk
about this a little later but I bought
this protein so I only bought a portion
of the sequence not the entire sequence
length so I have the ESP predictor score
here in purple I measured the peak area
by SRM here in gold and we can see the
correlation between the two on this
curve I've actually plotted the the
correlation so here we've got the ESP
predictor rank so we know 1 through 10
which one was the best Oh next to the
SRM rank and it's pretty much a scatter
plot right one of the best SRM proteins
is in the top three for the ESP
predictor the other ones are lower and
sure I might pick these to take a look
at they're not super horrible but it's
just not agreeing super well now I'm
coming from a targeted background and so
you might be like well sandy you're
probably just cherry picking here I
promise I'm not here's four other
proteins from the same project we had
the same issue maybe two proteins are in
the top three proteins and if you look
in the bottom right corner like none
none of these top proteins are in the
top three that were predicted by ESP
predictor
now here just the correlations for the
ESP predictor ranked next to the SRM
ranked and we can look at some other
prediction algorithms because I'm not
just bashing ESP predictor here okay we
can go to peptide Atlas it's a great
database a great resource but or what
they do is show you a whole bunch of
different algorithms all next to each
other so that's what's here on the right
hand side of this curve is for a set of
proteins you've got scores from a bunch
of different algorithms ok and if we use
these peptide Atlas scores so here's the
ESP predictor score again that we pulled
from peptide Atlas and we can use the
peptide suitability score right this is
just a different algorithm that's
actually worse than peptide Atlas for
the specific for the specific experiment
the peptide says score also seems to be
much worse than the ESP predictor score
and lastly the detectability predictor
score and again these are just four
different algorithms that you can use
that have different ways of predicting
what peptides are going to show up the
best and so what we're finding here is
that they do okay but if you really want
to develop that that assay was great
signal where you're getting the best
limits of detection the best sensitivity
this might not be the way to start right
picking peptides that aren't giving you
the best response
and generally like just remember that
this machine doesn't have a brain right
this machine learning algorithm doesn't
actually have a brain but we do okay we
can get our data and we can think about
this and say well okay so we need to get
our own data but these prediction
algorithms are fed by data so why don't
they work right why why can't we feed
data in to these prediction algorithms
to get out what we want and so we can
actually look at look at how the state
is collected to answer this question so
a third method for picking your peptides
are using DDA data repositories okay so
this is data dependent acquisition and
it's a very common discovery proteomics
technique so a lot of these these
various algorithms used EDA data to to
train alright and so this is this is
what I'm showing here from peptide Atlas
is that this is the the empirical
suitability score based on the DDA data
and if we look at this this looks a lot
like those curves or those plots that we
were looking at before and so why
doesn't this work well because abundance
in DDA data is calculated based on
spectrum counts so now on this curve you
see the SRM peak area here on your left
in purple and the right hand y-axis RDD
a spectrum counts okay and these don't
seem to correlate very well and because
we're training our algorithms with the
DDA data that does it correlate to SRM
data why would we expect those
algorithms to correlate
so in summary why doesn't PDA data work
spectrum counts is not the same thing as
ms/ms peak area right so we can also
look at the ms1 peak area too to try and
do this so you've got here now SRM peak
area versus ms1 peak area and it's the
same story right so spectrum counts ms1
peak area they're not going to be the
same as your tandem mass spectral peak
area and so well why don't we just use
SRM data to populate SRM transition list
so we can do that there's actually from
the the same makers of peptide Atlas
there's SRM Atlas and this is a
repository for SRM data okay and this is
great you can use it um the one issue
that you might come across here is that
in the repository data even though it
might correlate pretty well with SRM
data collected on your instrument versus
my instrument versus fils instrument you
might be missing some data right because
with SRM again we're looking at very
targeted things these are the peptides
that the researchers that uploaded their
data we're interested in and so these
are the only peptides there's data for
right and so if we want to use this V a
V n ap the second most abundant peptide
for some reason we don't have
information on that so in summary when
we're talking about data repositories
and predicted prediction algorithms I
can use these not the same as I should
use these and I just asked that using
carefully carefully about how you are
how you're picking the data how you're
picking your peptides and ask yourself
the question is is this what you want
for your experiment because this is the
very base fundamental just structure of
your assay and if it's not done well
you're not going to have as good of an
assay as you could write so just
do it just do the experiment okay and
we'll talk about how to do this
experiment to empirically derive your
transition list for your experiment all
right
here is my general workflow for you you
produce a recombinant protein standard
you monitor all tryptic peptide and
we'll talk about why that's enclosed
will do a peptide response analysis an
IRT calibration through this whole time
we're going to be refining our
transition transition list and then at
the very end we're going to validate our
a site all right so let's start talking
about how we get recombinant protein
standard rather than buying these
peptide standards so you can buy it so
that's that's an option it's actually
not often not all that expensive
sometimes it is it depends on the
protein you have to just check it out
it's this case by case I did want to
give you an example of when you might
you might have to have to rethink buying
your protein so or maybe rethink your
supplier supplier so here's a datasheet
for a protein from an unnamed supplier
and if we look in at the various things
they tell us about our recombinant
protein there is a proprietary
purification process okay that's not too
weird I would really like it if they
said like HPLC UV and showed me some
spectra but this is fine it's also yes
you're confident full-length protein
with an n-terminal proprietary tag so
they have a predicted molecular weight
they're not going to tell me what their
end terminal tag is and that's really
hard for mass spectrometry right if you
just have a chunk of the protein if you
have a tag that you don't know is there
your sequences are going to be different
right and you just need to know that
when you're going into it and so anytime
I buy protein from a supplier I actually
insist that they send me what they have
written down as the sequence for what
would be the sequence for the protein
because if you look at the 70 point oh
seven kilo daltons the predicted
molecular weight for the
protein and we look at the Unipro
database that's supposed to be 45 kilo
daltons right so there's a huge tag on
this there's basically a small protein
attached to our protein
also this is $650 for 10 micrograms
which is pretty darn expensive and if
you want to look at the data sheet it's
a broken link so this raised some flags
and I actually ended up going to another
supplier and we'll check out this other
supplier so it's the same protein you
look at the datasheet they give you a
lovely gel with the full molecular
weight range 14 kilo daltons all the way
up to 120 right sometimes you'll get
these where they'll just like zoom in on
this range that they expect it to show
up in which by the way note that it's 45
right around where we expect where this
this protein to show up but they'll just
cut out that slice of it and give you
that picture and you won't know like
really the purity right on the purity by
the way they say it's greater than 95% I
look at their SDS page gel I agree with
that and it's a 6 hiss tag at the end
terminus they're very clear they have
the gene encoding net1 to gly 403 so we
know what sequence we're going to get
out of there and they tell us what it's
in okay so we're in sodium acetate
sodium chloride and glycerol so this is
really important because some stuff such
as glycerol makes it really hard to do
like an amino acid analysis clothes are
all the huge interference there and so
if we wanted to sequence the protein
ourselves or do an amino acid analysis
of some sort we might have some trouble
with this guy specifically it might have
to figure out a way to get rid of that
glycerol but it's good to know about
option 2 forgetting our proteins is
actually just to make it ourselves and
so thermo actually sells this kit that
makes it really really easy to just
express proteins in ugli the HeLa lysate
so you just you can expand purify and
sequence at cDNA clone you can often
just by those do in vitro transcription
translation with this kit and then you
can enrich the protein of interest via
glutathione sepharose resin so so we've
got this glutathione tag on the end of
the cDNA clone and we just pull that
and then what we can do is actually
spike in a heavy label of one of the
peptides in the GST tag okay and then we
can plot this so here on this
calibration curve we're looking at the
ratio of the light to heavy peptide from
the GST tag on the y axis and then just
the concentration of the peptide on the
x axis and we can actually calibrate
this we can have a pretty good idea of
how much protein we've synthesized and
it's cheap you can make 25 to 500
femtomole x'
per IV t experiment less than 20 bucks
of protein which is great and this is
enough protein to last for quite a while
so next now that we figure out how to
get our standard let's talk about how to
pick our peptides okay so if this white
box is a space that contains all the
predicted tryptic peptides from a
protein what we're going to do is look
at a subset of these peptides that are a
2 plus peptide a parent ion that will
dissociate into a 1 plus product diam
now if we have room in our method right
by room and I our method I mean if we
can like look at that many things
because we are limited in how many
transitions we can look at in the mess
RMS a at a single time so we'll look at
all the two-plus peptide to 1 plus
product ion transitions then if we've
got time we can look at some
confirmatory be ion transitions and then
if we've still got room in that method I
would go in and look at the 3 plus 2 1
or 2 plus B in Y ion series okay and
this is just because these 2 plus 2 1
plus y iron peptides actually tend to
show up the best if you look at a lot of
SRM methods that have been developed and
even in your discovery data
oftentimes you see that this why I am
series is the one that really guides you
to what this peptide was
an example let's look at a protein and
look at the portion of the sequence that
I purchased so I only had a portion of
the sequence but here are the options
for the tryptic peptides from that
portion of the sequence that I purchased
and then we can plot these so here's our
first chromatogram of the of the seminar
on the x axis you see retention time
over the course of the experiment so for
those of you that are familiar with
discovery proteomics and targeted
proteomics you can see here that this is
a 20 minute experiment where as a lot of
discovery experiments are 2 hours plus
right so this is much faster than a
discovery experiment often is on the
y-axis we've just got the intensity and
we're just measuring the intensity of
each peptide over time and so I've shown
you here there are spots for each one of
the peptides from the protein of
interest for us I can zoom in on this
x-axis and just kind of prove to you
that the peptides that I say are there
are actually there and then now that
we've seen some peptides we need to
constrain this list because this is
going to be huge okay so if we look at
say a specific protein we want to pick
out the peptides that are unique to that
protein so peptides that aren't going to
be found in other proteins in the
proteome ok and what this allows us to
do is say that if I see say here for
example the LAPD EPS ID I see this
peptide I know I know that this protein
is present right we also want to remove
any peptides that have an ambiguous
solution profile so this is actually
just one peptide it elutes at two
different points I believe this one
contains prolene which is often the
cause of this if you have two prolene
isomers in a peptide you'll get multiple
peaks you also sometimes get just get
chairs out of these guys so here's a
little chair peak and this is actually
my rotation student Dion
as favorite peek this is the back peek
can happen sometimes as well now when we
have these and be ambiguous Peaks we can
we can counteract it a little bit right
so this is why I said you know look at
that three plus charge state two if you
can because we look at the two plus
charge state for a specific peptide it
may come out with multiple peaks and we
don't know which is actually the one we
should quantify on but if we look at the
three plus charge state we can pick the
peak that corresponds to the aleutian of
the peptide we expect right because in
this three plus charge state there's
only one peak and the two plus and 3
plus charge state should be alluding at
exactly the same time because it's just
that the peptide elutes and then we make
two different charge states out of it we
can also go through once we've figured
out where all of our peaks are what are
good transitions are and remove low and
noisy transitions so here in red you see
that yet sometimes you measure Y ions
that just aren't there
and so you want to delete all of those
out right so we've started with this big
net and we're narrowing everything down
trying to just kick out anything that's
not giving us good information so once
we've done that we can narrow this down
to peptides that respond right and then
the next thing we want to do is actually
look at the stability of these peptides
that respond because we want our peak
area to change with concentration not
time right so we started doing this in
the Macross lab where we actually do
this incubation for 72 hours of the
peptides in the autosampler at 4 degrees
Celsius now there's a very specific
reason we use 72 hours 72 hours is the
amount of time that you need to put a
sample in on a Friday and keep your auto
sampler running till Monday so that your
you know tech or grad student or postdoc
doesn't have to you know come in on
Sunday and maybe try to skip paying for
parking
and maybe have to talk their way out of
parking ticket on campus not that that
ever happened but you know we're just
going to prevent that from happening but
if we look at this data for peptides
from this protein we actually see two of
the peptides switch abundance right
between the two days and we we can see
this happening here some of this is just
a percent change over 72 hours for all
of the peptides in this protein and I've
drawn red lines at plus or minus 10%
right so we're trying to keep that CV
really tight so these two peptides of
all the peptides we looked at there are
two peptides that we think are staying
stable for this experiment
and now the macaws lab has done a lot of
these experiments and we've uploaded
this to passport Lacoste lab org
it's a protei protein assay portal
stability data and you can actually just
come in here and pick any protein you
want go to an interactive view and get
results from these experiments that we
did for you and we measure all the
peptides from the sequence of the
protein that we had and so you can you
can go in there and get the information
that you want that we've already
collected for you so we now have talked
about peptides that respond and we've
talked about now reliable peptides we
also want to make sure that our peptides
are are selective that we're selective
for peptides but they're not interfered
with right so if we put something in a
different matrix I can measure something
in ammonium bicarbonate or you know a
yeast background but if I put it in
human there's going to be different
peptides there and we're gonna have
different interferences so you always
want to take your peptides measure
amount of matrix make sure to remove any
transitions that are interfered with or
assess any matrix suppression of peptide
signal so there's a few ways to do this
you can just spike into negative you can
use Sai Lac you can use a diverged
species so what I use a lot or have used
a lot is chicken serum for human plasma
and then for clinical
Berman's there's actually an assurance
interferences kit that send Diagnostics
son Diagnostics cells got lipids and
small molecules and a bunch of stuff
that we expect to interfere with
proteomics experiments I just want to
show you that this is a real thing so if
you look here at this peptide in a
buffer so you I'm showing the two and a
three plus transition state 3 plus
transition state kind of stinks but it
shows us which peptide from the 2 plus
or which peak from the 2 plus is
actually our peptide and then we look at
this in chicken-liver background because
this was from human and we just totally
don't even see it right so don't be
scared this might happen to you you want
to leave as many options going in as you
can
transitions also get interferes with and
so here's a different peptide that looks
great in buffer beautiful signal and
then when we go into our matrix we lose
an order of magnitude and signal and we
see that some of their best transitions
are very obviously interfered with so
for example the pink transition here has
a nice little tail that it didn't have
when we looked at it in the buffer
alright the next thing I want to talk
about it's actually being able to do
quantitative analysis on these because
what we have are these Gaussian Peaks
that were measuring and we want to
estimate the true peak shape by
selecting them so I had a project where
I was looking at 658 transitions so
that's where these numbers are coming
from right so if I'm measuring
a whole bunch of transitions
concurrently right say they say I only
get to come back to the original
transition the first transition in my
list every No seven seconds okay well
then I'm only going to take a few points
over the course of a peak and if I try
to trace a Gaussian distribution to fit
this it it just totally doesn't fit
right but if I can take ten ten points
ten pine points across the peak this
actually fits quite well and so we
always want to try and get ten time
points across the peak and we have about
twenty to thirty second peak widths so
if I was trying to measure all of these
transitions all at once I would have
this seven second cycle
4.6 cycles a peak that's not going to
work very well so what we're going to do
instead is calibrate our our assay to an
IRT okay so what this means is basically
we take a set of peptides that we know
span the range across our retention time
and we measure our samples relative to
these so we can spike them in just like
the the retention time calibration extra
in and measure peptides relative to that
let me just show you how nicely this
work so so first there's a whole bunch
of different options they all work fine
and if if we have a set of peptides here
on the x-axis I'm showing you the index
retention time and on the y-axis is the
measured retention time and we want them
to all fall within five minutes okay and
that or within a five minute window and
that will allow us to have 2.5 second
cycle time right with this five-minute
window we're only measuring 250
transitions concurrently which gives us
a 2.5 second cycle time so if we take
our proteins that we measure in buffer
and throw them in chicken-liver this is
about what it looks like
okay but if we correct for our retention
time calibrators we can actually get
them nice and tight back around our
original line in our different matrix
okay and so this is how you can actually
schedule the experiments to be able to
only measure a small subset of peptides
at any given time kind of save yourself
some time right so that for the last
little bit of this talk I want to talk
about a assay validation okay this is
kind of the last spot we have an assay
now but we have to validate it or else
it's not really worth anything okay if
we're talking about clinical assay
validation there's six points we want to
get we want to validate reproducibility
stability linearity a little oq
interferences
and then like storage stability right
more stability under stress and so what
have we done so far
well we've looked at the stability the
selectivity in the ax accuracy so let's
talk about precision and in talking
about precision I want to talk about
some internal standards okay and and how
important they are so this was a time
course and this is actually April 1
spiked in and measured at different
digestion times and I did replicates
because every good ever good analytical
chemist likes replicants right here are
my error bars they're huge they're
ridiculously huge and so if you look
into this with the two different
replicates replicate one something
happened at the higher time points right
we're just getting a lower signal for
all of the higher time points which is
what's leading to this peak area change
so what I actually did was normalize
this signal to my internal standards
okay if I have internal standards I can
normalize the signal so this is the peak
area ratio to some stable isotope
labeled internal standards of this
peptide and I can restore the signal
right and I can I can bring down the CV
of this experiment or of these
measurements right it's always important
to include standards now you you also
might want to include a protein internal
standard so back here we're talking
about using a peptide internal standard
where I spike it in and just measure to
look at instrument performance here
right because it's probably what
happened is my instrument just wasn't
performing well but you can also use a
protein internal standard to assess
different digestion conditions and
sample preparation issues so for example
in one experiment I have both a peptide
and the protein internal standard there
and so the standard is a fillet one and
here's a peptide from a boy white now
the peptide shows up just fine but the
protein internal standard did not okay
and or the peptide from the protein so
these are actually differentially
labeled one is 15 and
one is labeled on the c-terminus and so
what we can conclude here is that the
instruments working fine because I see
my peptide internal standard but
something happened with the digestion it
didn't digest the protein th la out of
my protein standard and so my data is in
question right so you can you can
real-time monitor and do QC and QA of
your experiments by using internal
standards and I just want to give a
little bit of a shout out to the
internal standard I used it's currently
sold by CIL as prettiest QC we helped
develop it and so these are the
differentially labeled peptide and
protein internal standards so the
peptides are labeled just at the at the
c-terminus and the protein is 15 and
labeled so they show up differently we
mix those together and can add them to a
bio sample and digest that and analyze
it and have all in one standard that you
can just bike in so that's been pretty
nice and you actually can can look at a
lot of different stuff with this so for
example retention time drifts over time
so from injection 10 out to 400 145 on a
single column you get some retention
time tricks you can actually use this to
help recalibrate any IRT measurements
you might be doing and you can also use
it for normalization so for example if
you just take the peak area of a peptide
or cv might be pretty high because their
peak area might drop over time so this
is injection 29 90 and 120 but if you
normalize these to the internal standard
you can really bring the CD back up so
we can restore our CV
we also want to assess our
reproducibility so the CV of the whole
experiment and this is actually done
commonly in what's called a five by five
assay so you can take a set of samples
and store them and analyze five samples
on each of five different days and get
the season's first intraday so on each
day you can take a CV of samples from
day one a through E then you can also
get an intern a CV where you can look at
sample a on each of the five days now by
taking the sum of the squares you can
get the total CV for the variance of the
measurement of any given peptide that
you might be interested in okay so we
can look at this for some real samples
so this is work that was that I did with
Deanna poubelle who's a PhD student at
the University of Washington and she's
looking at peptides in CSF so she's
looking at 944 peptides from 268
proteins in her assay and she actually
took the coefficient of variation of
each of these peptides and plotted them
as a histogram and drew a line at 20%
and that's what we consider quantitative
is 20% coefficient of variation and it
turns out 71% of her peptides actually
were had a CV of less than 20% so could
be used for quantification in the range
that we were looking at and about 30%
had a high CV
now those can still be used for
detection but not necessarily for
quantification
all right now that we've talked about
accuracy stability selectivity and
precision let's talk about the last
little bit of assay validation the last
thing you need to do to have a
quantitative assay is assessing
linearity and lower limit of
quantification
and as we get into this I just want to
remind everyone but the measurements are
all relative everything is relative so
for example weight great weight is just
relative to this block of metal that
weighs one kilogram we just have a 1
kilogram piece right and so if we want
to measure a narwhal or kangaroo that's
all relative to this block that's kept
super safe under double chambered glass
even our atomic-scale right it's just
relative to carbon carbon is 12 carbon
12 is 12
we just said 12 it's not actually a math
right and I want you to keep that in
mind when we talk about quantification
because we're always doing relative
quantification and there are always
caveat to that so I'm going to talk
briefly about three different ways to
quantify we can use an external
calibration curve you can do a sample
dilution series or you can measure
differentially alright so we'll start
with external calibration curves so just
bringing you back to your quantitative
analysis 101 class right let's look at a
real calibration curve it's actually a
sigmoid at the very bottom you have a
limit of detection your lower limit of
quantification is right about that
inflection point and your upper limit of
quantification is the upper inflection
point in between these two there is a
linear dynamic range some rules of thumb
when you're building quality calibration
curves if you want at least 6 points
over the course of the calibration curve
specifically one at your blank 5 in the
linear range preferably one at your
lower limit of quantification when you
are preparing these what you should do
is actually do kind of a hopping with
two different dilution series so you
prepare your top concentration they
compare your sector you prepare your
second concentration and you do serial
dilutions of each of these two and this
allows you to see if there are any
pipetting errors when you prepare your
calibration curve we can make
calibration curves with either peptides
or proteins there's some pros and cons
for each so peptides are easier to get
but you don't get any of that digestion
variability and people do this a lot
people are really into synthetic peptide
calibration curves
a protein calibration curve however
accounts for all your sample preparation
variability and you probably already
have them from developing the method one
other thing I want to comment on about
peptide and protein calibration curves
is peptide calibration curves cannot be
used to tell you the concentration of a
protein in a sample you're doing peptide
quantification not protein
quantification and so really all you're
doing is defining a minimum amount of a
protein that must be present in the
sample but depending on the digestion
efficiency of that protein there may be
more so I just want to leave you with
that if you take nothing else away from
this about calibration curves
it's that peptide calibration curves
cannot be used to actually calibrate for
a protein another nice thing about these
protein calibrators is just like in
method development they provide multiple
targets so you can actually plot five
different linearly responding peptides
from a specific protein and pick out
which one responds best in this case the
GL Y peptide assuming it's not
interfered with and it's unique in
everything would probably be a very good
prospect for breeze for quantification
we can also use this information to
finally do our last little refinements
on our transition list so for example
our normalized peak area here is shown
on a right and 3 or sorry 5 different
concentration points are shown on the
x-axis and we can see that this blue
transition like really isn't bringing
much to our method right it's just kind
of floating up our signal and increasing
our variability if we look at a
different peptide this green this green
transition is really really not doing
anything actually none of these
transitions are doing anything this
peptide is not changing constant curve
response with concentration so this
whole peptide can get cut and these are
things that are our calibration curves
can show us we want to see this linear
decrease of our transitions and our
peptides with concentration
we can do this in a label-free or a
stable isotope labeled method so a
stabilized labeled method you would
spike in heavy labeled peptides of
integer interest at a background level
and normalize everything to these
peptides okay here's what a calibration
curve might look like for it we've got a
beautiful r-squared value nice and
linear this is this is a beautiful way
to do these experiments great for
normalization you do need at least 95
percent purity light and heavy peptides
and those are those can be kind of
expensive right now you're buying a lot
if you're spending this much on it but
it will last you for a while but it's a
pretty big front-end investment now if
you're doing label-free you're just
going to look at the protein you want to
see but you still need to normalize to
something and so these are where those
external QC samples right the produce QC
that sort of thing is really useful
because you can use it to normalize all
of your peak areas and if you do this
you still get really really nice results
so here is for another peptide and we're
looking at the label-free data
normalized to my internal standards and
our r-squared value is also beautiful
right so all of these work quite well as
long as you have very well vetted
peptides now you can use this to
determine the LOD and loq right so
there's an MS stats package that goes
into R and works is compatible with a
skyline which is a software developed by
the Macross lab it's freely available
and it's it's called nonlinear Kwantlen
and what it does is a bilinear fit of
the data so I'll show you some of this
to show you
to show you what that actually looks
like some other features of interest for
MS stats is that it does integrate with
skyline
it has quant and stats tools and lots
and lots of plotting options you can do
volcano you can do residual I actually
just found yesterday the TMT
quantification is also included in m/s
stats if you want to do that this is
what the data looks like when you plot
it so you see your little hockey stick
sort of calibration curve here and let
me show you some real calibration curves
okay well this is what you might
actually see when you when you do
calibration curves so here's a big zoom
out of a super super linear one this one
looks great I didn't even get low enough
to hockey stick it you might see
something that hockey sticks really
nicely had lots of variance in your in
the low concentrations or you might see
something that's basically flat and
never gets above the 90 percent upper
bound of noise so basically is just
noise all the time you picked a bad
peptide but you wouldn't know unless you
actually did these experiments which is
why they're so important and you can use
EMA stats to get your llq okay and so
they actually when it plots those curves
it just pops it out or just writes out
the llo cue for you as well as the LOD
and I just wanted to leave you guys with
a warning on this of just know where
you're getting your definitions from
right so some things are defined by
variance right based on variance for
your LOD and ll OQ and sometimes your
LOD n ll cure decide defined based on a
signal-to-noise ratio of the background
or the blank but it's important to know
these things all right so the switch
gears a little bit here because I've
talked a whole lot about spiking
something into an exogenous maist
matrix in this case most of this was
done with chicken serum but what if I
don't have a good matrix all right
I only have the third and worst matrix I
have to use my sample itself as a matrix
and so what you can do is called
standard edition all right so external
standard you would be spiked with
something into a matrix that does not
have any of that compound in it to begin
with
whereas with standard edition your
spiking into a sample that does contain
it okay so your sample is shown here in
black there would be a response and then
a mocked up sample response if you
spiked it it's just a little bit higher
and this also should be linear right
that's why we can take advantage of this
is that the linearity should be the same
you can measure your sample and then
different concentration points when you
spike it in you should be able to draw a
line through these points and be able to
determine your limit of detection
now you can't assess your limit of
quantification you can only assess
whether your sample is above the limit
of quantification so you can say oh yeah
I can quantify this but you just you
can't say but and I can and fill this
low right but this is still important
information and useful information
so another way to quantify is actually
by doing just a dilution series of your
sample in in plasma and so we actually
did this for an alzheimer's disease
study that we were working on
Alzheimer's disease is a really huge
health crisis right now it's estimated
to have a 1.1 trillion dollar health
care cost in 2050 and it's known to be
based in protein so looking at April
lipoprotein II there are three different
variants that are their normal high risk
or protective for Alzheimer's disease
and so what we actually did here were
looking for different proteins in
Alzheimer's disease and we just took our
human sample and diluted it up in
chicken okay so our one hundred percent
concentration our human sample our
lowest concentration is chicken and we
did do our two different dilution series
right to make sure that we take care of
any systemic errors and what you can see
is when you do this you get nice clear
results so this is for the protein the
peptide ihw from co 3 ok you can also
use healthy disease pools so for example
if i if the chicken serum didn't work I
could use the Alzheimer's disease sample
and then a healthy sample and I and do
delusions of the two pools to
demonstrate that the measurement is
linear between the two so for example I
can take 100% healthy down to 100%
Alzheimer's and so if we show this data
safer apoe4 some mocked up data what you
would see is that it's linear in between
the healthy and diseased patients
so with that I just want to kind of
summarize the important things about
targeted method development strategies
that we've talked about today so things
to avoid our predictive algorithms data
repositories and DDA data these don't
accurately reflect what you're going to
see by SRM how to make a gold star assay
measure your peptides of interest
evaluate the stability and matrix effect
do all of these evaluations include
peptide and protein standards and you
have to calibrate you can calibrate in
lots of different ways using external
calibration curves
standard addition curves or using
healthy disease dilutions but you have
to calibrate to be quantitative with
that
I would like to thank the Makah slab
because again this work was done in the
Makah slab NIH for funding as well as
the genome Sciences Department for
funding and everyone who helped me with
this work I also want to put up some
resources for everyone so this webinar
will be posted for six months and so
what I wanted to give you are just some
resources so this is a sample
preparation protocol for human plasma so
don't worry about writing it down now
that you can come back and pause right
here and copy it down if you if you want
to try and use it I have another
protocol here for doing from cell
homogenate
some go to nano LC methods for
proteomics experiments are here with all
of our parameters and the type of
packing material and everything we use
as well as some selected resources for
further reading on this sort of thing
everything from quantitative proteomics
to just clinical chemistry and doing
proteomics from there so with that I'd
be happy to take any questions thank you
thank you dr. Spencer for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. Spencer will answer as many
questions its time permits so the first
question is what is the maximum number
of transitions that can be measured at
once yes so that's actually going to
depend on your instrument and I think
one of the biggest things there is how
long you have to measure for right so
your sensitivity is going to be
proportional to the amount of time you
measure a transition and so I I like a
minimum transition era
sorry dwell time of about 10
milliseconds obviously going higher is
better but it says I found it to be kind
of the balance so with that said as my
dwell time is going to be 10
milliseconds on most triple quads
probably 450 to 500 concurrent
transitions you could measure at a
single time thank you
next one is do you have to do such long
digestion or can you add more trypsin
and digest for a shorter period of time
yeah so this is actually a really good
point I didn't talk much about it one of
the slow things about a lot of what I do
and you actually see in the resources I
put up there is that I do an 18-hour
digestion for a lot of experiments so
one thing is that a lot of my work was
done in plasma which is notoriously
difficult to digest due to protease
inhibitors
and so I'm actually using a ton of
trypsin in there but you definitely can
add more trypsin especially if you're
using the cheaper like the cheaper grade
trypsin not pretty omics grade trypsin
you can add more in and one thing I'd
actually suggest doing if you're going
to do that if you add in the trypsin let
it go for 30 minutes to 2 hours and then
do another spike of trypsin thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question why do you use both peptides
and proteins in your internal standard
yeah so this is a really good question
so both peptides and proteins in the
internal standard are because they bring
different things to the table so
peptides you know you should see right
so if you don't see your peptide
internal standard there's probably
something wrong with your setup or your
sampler like your your sample itself say
you're not picking up enough sample to
actually analyze or your nano LC tip has
gone bad or something like that but if
you can see your peptide internal
standard and not your protein internal
standard right you can specify that okay
well the protein internal standard it
should behave like all the other
proteins in the sample right so you can
use that to kind of differentiate where
a problem might be rather than being in
the situation where okay I spent you
know hours prepping these samples
18-hour digestion whole bunch of
pipetting in between making my methods
getting everything set up I fire these
precious precious samples that I say got
as biopsies and I don't see any signal
why not right and a lot of the time when
you do have a instrument problem if you
don't include a lot of different
different standards to test for
different things it does turn into well
I don't have signal why and so it's to
kind of keep you from being in that
position
well I would like to once again thank
dr. Spencer for her presentation I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today we'll be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank our educational
sponsor Agilent for today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through April 2019
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye